par un papa papa me paraît peu probable
qu'elle poussière alors
je veux mettre la radio un peu de
musique madonna du coeur à l'ouvragé
[Musique]
sylvain gonda de mademoiselle futile
monsieur travelling plutôt que l'amitié
ben
non c'est fini déjà j'adore cette
chanson oui et c'est bien vrai ce
qu'elle dit d'ailleurs rien ne vaut des
amis d'un mois d'ailleurs j'ai des amis
merveilleux et à françois jules il un
facteur et puis même même monsieur du
snav après tout on se dispute souvent
mais je les aime bien j'aimerais
d'ailleurs bien leur faire une surprise
les invités à dîner par exemple
malheureusement je cuisine très mal
enfin c'est leur avis du moins parce que
moi je suis le roi du gloubiboulga
malheureusement personne n'aime ça
je ne peux quand même pas demander à un
jury de préparer le dîner ce ne serait
plus une surprise
mais ça y est ma tante adélaïde oui elle
va me sauver
c'est la solution
alors oui tante adélaïde c'est moi
casimir oui j'ai un petit service à te
demander oui je voudrais inviter des
amis à dîner on voulait faire une
surprise
avant are merci alors tu me proposes du
saucisson en entrée c'est parfait c'est
parfait oui oui jambon avec salade de
riz mayonnaise très bien très bon oui et
une tarte aux pommes en dessert ce sera
parfait oui merci non ne te dérange pas
tant adélaïde envoie sa part la poste
nous avons un facteur excellent
oui d'autant plus il a invité également
alors ça tombe bien oui merci un merci
allez au revoir quand adélaïde
formidable bon eh bien il me reste plus
qu'à aller prévenir tous padam padam
avons casimir et moi je compte vont
d'humeur peut-être eh bien ça ne se
passera pas si je vais lui faire mais un
farce dont il se souviendra
non la fabrique de briques ouais je
téléphone de la part de casimir pourriez
vous lui faire envoyer 20 kg d'un break
en taquinant oui c'est ça à la maison de
casimir
pouvait plus de livres 1 mais c'est très
bien je veux dire ça n'est pas grave oui
envoyé par la poste le facteur connais
très bien la maison c'est ça c'est ça
merci roi
ça m'étonnerait bien que le facteur et
le temps de s'occuper du bon dîner tante
adélaïde il aura bien du mal à
transporter toutes les briques quand
j'ai commandé pour les invités de
casimir ils mangeront des brics quoi
pour leur dîner
[Rires]
tout à l'heure françois j'ai tout rangé
j'ai fermé mon kiosque comment julie tu
t'en vas déjà mais déjà on sait pas
encore l'heure de la fermeture du jardin
oui mais je voudrais changer drame avant
d'aller chez casimir s'est gelé il
s'agit d'un dîner très simple entre amis
oui ça fait rien j'aimerais lui faire
plaisir en faisant honneur à son
invitation
tu as raison ça lui fera certainement
plaisir mais moi je reste comme je suis
c'est très bien à tout à l'heure à tout
à l'heure j'ai dit bonjour factor
bonsoir momo je suis chez casimir ce
sera tout à l'heure oulala ayrault on
vous m'aimez vous révéler revient chargé
ou
poursuivre et et je m'en serais bien
passé 1 figurez vous qu après une
journée de travail bien remplie
il ya le directeur de la fabrique de
briques qui a téléphoné pour demander si
je pouvais me chargée de l'envoi de
brink chez casimir l envoi de prik ouais
mais que peut-il enfin je sais pas moi
tout être arrangé sa maison aux nanos
factor ça m'étonnerait sa maison est
entièrement en bois
en gros si on n'avait pas songé il
tracteur ouais j'espère que casimir n'a
pas l'intention de nous faire manger des
prix que ce soit ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie
j'y pense et quelque chose de bizarre
oui oui le directeur de la fabrique de
briques m'a dit qu'il n'avait pas
reconnu la voix de casimir facteurs il y
à là dessus un mystère écouter partait
de 20 mois je faire une petite enquête
et georges ensuite chez casimir le
travail
voici celle où as tu partais lanceur a
alors vraiment leonhardt ne vont pas
dîné avec nous non non tu m'invites trop
tard de plus j'ai rendez vous avec tomba
pourrait bien tant pis pour toi je vais
aller voir si monsieur du snob et
rentrer car il n'était pas chez lui tout
à l'heure allez salut
tant pis pour lui
ravie d'être hautain à son bon dîner
c'est moi qui vais passer une très bonne
soirée quand ils verront ils n'ont que
des briques en guise de dîner
casimir quasi mais
bon il est pas encore là ça fait rien je
vais rentrer les brèches ouf
moi je laisse ici tient il les mettra où
il voudra lui
le facteur vous êtes là ça y est j'ai
fini mon enquête au projet fait vite moi
je viens peine d'arriver il a suffi de
trois petits coups de téléphone pour
tout comprendre
les briques c'est une farce de léonard
pour vous occuper occupé mais pourquoi
bien pour que vous n'ayez pas le temps
de retourner au bureau de poste où vous
attend un colis envoyés par la tante
adélaïde et qui contient le bon dîner
casimir veut nous offrir ce soir pour
suivre va falloir que je retourne à la
poste et que je rapporte ici le colis
dans l'attentât et l'ail et b vous
attardez chez vous non dits des
approches j'ai cours mais françois ou
allons nous mettre les briques ne vous
inquiétez pas je m'en charge l'important
c'est que vous fier de retour pour les
lignes
c'est vraiment dommage que monsieur des
snobs éduquer terry pour la journée au
pas enfin cela nous laisse une part de
tarte en plus alors qu'il a heureusement
moi j'en prendrais volontiers
c'est que le métier de facteur c'est un
métier qui donne sa
chance et nous votre chanson oui ça
l'est
écoutez je reconnais une chose c'est
après un bon repas il faut toujours une
bonne chanson
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier masson géographe
j'aurais pu même être chaud très
j'aurais pu être petit bassin copie the
milk halle aux gras
mais j'ai choisi d'être facteur
quand je suis le hu à val-d'or temps
grâce
je suis l'ami des jolis mots
l'amoureux des phrases et ses vidéos
je les emporte sur mon
seul un penchant
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
meunier maçon ou géographe
j'aurais pu même être chanteur
tu aurais pu être cultivateurs
confiseurs ou mécanographe
mais j'ai choisi d'être impacté car je
suis le roi de l'orthographe
j'aime les lettres
les écritures guézé charmante
quand leur taux graff est respectée cela
mon
chanteur
j'aurais pu être plombier zingueur
maniema sans bouger au grain
j'aurais pu même être chante
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mégalomane
j'ai choisi d'être factuel
je suis là
leur programme
dès que commande
tout le long du chemin que je chante les
gens jettent mon arrivée cela mangeant
en
non
j'aurais pu être donc les zingueurs
veniez masson rouge et or
j'aurais pu même être un chanteur
j'aurais pu être cultivateurs confiseurs
ou mécano
mais je choisis des tracteurs pour ceux
plus
je choisis d'être patins pour sûr
mais j'ai choisi d'être fatale
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'y pense beaucoup avez vous mis les
briques à l'élever carré eh bien je les
ai livré à celui que les avaient
commandées à à léonard